[Music]
hello everyone its Alicia Malone welcome
to Fandango indie movie guide and
because it's Star Wars week with Star
Wars the last Jedi being released in
theaters
no one was brave enough to go up against
Star Wars so there's not much opening
this week so instead I'm gonna talk a
little bit about the Golden Globes
nominations that happened earlier this
week and then take a look ahead to the
following week because it's holiday
season and there's a lot coming up so
starting with the Golden Globes
nominations overall the shape of water
led the pack with seven nominations
followed by the post and three
billboards outside a being Missouri
which both picked up six nominations
biggest snobs for me it was a Greta
Gerwig for Lady Bird in the best
director category only seven times in
the last 75 years has a woman been
nominated for the best director category
at the Golden Globes and only once has
she won that was Barbra Streisand in
1983 I was also disappointed not to see
Jordan Peele be in the directing
category forget out as well all the
money in the world was another surprise
just because nobody but the H FPA has
actually seen this movie yet but it must
be good because it picked up several
nominations this was the film directed
by Ridley Scott where he replaced Kevin
Spacey
with Christopher Plummer who picked up a
Best Supporting Actor nomination and
this is gonna be the first time that an
actor who just shot a role a month ago
has been nominated Ferg on globe the
beak SiC was another one I really wish
was nominated particularly in the best
comedy or musical category and get out
also I missed out on a Best Screenplay
nomination for Jordan Peele which I
thought was a real shame because it is
such a tightly written script when you
look at the film and you see everything
it's foreshadowing at the beginning that
happens at the end
it is a masterful piece of work but
anyway the Golden Globes always
interesting so looking ahead to next
week as we ramp up towards Christmas
I've got two very brutal films so you
should check out the first is happy and
directed by mikael Chanukah and if
you've seen any of his films before like
a more or the white ribbon or funny
games then you'll know that he is
someone who loves to torture his
audiences
but he does it so so well this is an
unofficial sequel to a more with Isabel
Hooper and Jean Louie 20 yong reprising
their roles it has deep things to say
about social media it definitely does
not have a happy end but that's Mikael
Chanukah and it's got one of the most
interesting uses of the sea a song that
I have ever seen
[Music]
it's a karaoke scene that is anything
but joyful would you expect anything
less from Mikael Hanukkah and would you
want anything less
I say no happy and opens in theaters
from December 22
yeah also out that day is one of the
most brutal westerns I have ever seen
called hostiles this is directed by
Scott Cooper who's teaming up once again
with Christian Bale they last made out
of the furnace together and it's set in
the late 1890s and Christian Bale plays
an army captain who is trying to
transport an Indian family back to their
tribal lands I've got a war bag of
reasons to hate this will be done and it
will be done by you parades over women
change there's a lot of racial tension
in this movie and I was so glad to see a
lot of Native American Indians in the
cast and speaking the languages it will
rip your heart out Rosamond pike plays a
widow who is grieving the gory loss of
her family great cast it is well worth
the watch it's a slow burn but it's
engrossing and yes it's very violent but
I think necessary hostiles opens in
theaters from December 22 when we lay
our heads down out here we're all
prisoners and if you're after also
something brutal to watch at home over
the holidays from the 19th you can see
on Fandango now the killing of a sacred
deer now many people will wonder what
the hell's wrong with me when I say that
this is one of my favorite films of the
year but director yoga slam thermos has
such an original striking voice he made
the lobster and dogtooth and this film
is even darker than both of those
combined it stars Colin Farrell as a
doctor who strikes up a friendship with
a young boy played by Barry Keough and
they end up having almost a father-son
friendship and then it turns very very
dark indeed and threatens his entire
family I want to see one more thing I'm
really sorry about Bobby
it's nothing serious no it is Nicole
Kidman's also in the cast beautifully
shot well acted yes it will put you
through the wringer but once again I
think it is worth it
I'm sure you were all worried now about
my mental state but I just loved a movie
that really makes me feel something and
I want to know from you not about that
but about the Golden Globe nominations
what would the biggest snubs are the
biggest surprises for you let me know in
the comments below or on Twitter an
Alicia Malone and I'll see you next week
[Music]